Winter has come, and it's sent an avalanche
down on the HBO production offices.
In May of 2017, as Game of Thrones neared
its seventh and penultimate season on HBO,
the network announced that it was exploring
the idea of expanding the world of dragons,
White Walkers, and dudes whose maybe-girlfriends
are actually their aunts through multiple
spin-off series.
HBO set up five of these projects, all prequels
rather than straight-up spin-offs, according
to Thrones author George R.R.
Martin, and recently handed a pilot order
to one being run by Kingsman and Kick-Ass
writer Jane Goldman.
Franchise fans rejoiced at the news that at
least one of the spin-off series was in works.
But now their merriment and revels must come
to an end.
HBO president Casey Bloys had announced that
Goldman's project is the only Game of Thrones
spin-off moving forward at HBO.
The four others are as good as dead, sitting
dormant for the time being.
Bloys dropped the bombshell during the Television
Critics Association on Wednesday, July 25th,
telling those in attendance, "There are no
plans to make any others at this point."
According to Bloys, it was HBO's intention
from the start to brainstorm a bevy of projects
and then lock in just one series, allowing
creatives and executives to pour their passion
into a single project rather than split their
energy amongst various productions.
Bloys explained: "The reason we did multiple
scripts, in the development process, [is because
we knew] out of five we'd be lucky to get
one we're excited about."
At least for now, fans will simply have to
be satisfied with watching Goldman's series,
said to follow Westeros' descent from the
Golden Age of Heroes into a dark era that
will alter everything we know about the fictional
world's history, House Stark, and "the mysteries
of the east."
Will that be enough to quench their Thrones
thirst?
We don't know yet, but we do know some more
details about Goldman's prequel series.
After the Television Critics Association summer
session on Wednesday, Bloys sat down with
Deadline to discuss the prequel in more detail.
He revealed that the project will feature
an ensemble cast and highlight strong female
characters.
He also noted that, despite what some may
assume with a female showrunner like Goldman
on board, the prequel that centers on Westeros'
fall from the Golden Age of Heroes won't have
a female lead in the same way that Game of
Thrones has a male lead in Kit Harington's
Jon Snow.
Bloys explained: "There are very strong female
characters but it's an ensemble, there [are]
men and women [...] Jane is a very good writer.
We don't want to limit her to writing female
leads.
There are a lot of very complicated leads
in [the pilot]."
Game of Thrones is known for its complex female
characters, including Maisie Williams' sword-swinging
Arya Stark, Lena Headey's power-hungry Cersei
Lannister, and Gwendoline Christie's strong-yet-sweet
Brienne of Tarth, but the show has also sparked
controversy for its portrayal of some of its
leading ladies.
For years, viewers have criticized the way
showrunners David Benioff and D.B.
Weiss have presented the series' women, calling
for the creatives to "stop punishing" them
with public humiliation and physical and sexual
violence.
Bloys touched on the fact that the untitled
spin-off won't overwork itself trying to tie
up any potential threads left loose by Game
of Thrones or answer all the questions fans
of the series might have.
Instead, it will make the most of being its
own entity, one that features all the same
drama, tension, and shocks everyone loves
in Game of Thrones, while still standing separate
from the original fantasy epic.
Bloys elaborated: "Jane did not go into that
wanting to answer anything about Game of Thrones;
it was the story that spoke to her.
[...] It will feel very different because
it's 8,000 years before, it's a very different
setting, a very different time in Westeros.
It will feel different but still Game of Thrones."
Overall, this newness shouldn't scare you
off, diehard Game of Thrones fans.
Goldman actually created the spin-off series
with George R.R.
Martin based on a story the two developed
together, so you can rest assured that the
prequel is in capable hands.
How exactly those hands will shape the project,
we can't predict, but we're hoping the end
result is swell.